[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et l'invité
de 5 à 10 ce matin françois ursule et
bonjour oui bonjour monsieur vous êtes
trésorier de l'association martiniquaise
pour la promotion et d'industrie et la
promotion de l'industrie et vous avez
signé avec les chambres consulaires et
les organismes socioprofessionnels une
motion pour soutenir
l'octroi de mer avant de nous intéresser
à cette motion à cette charte nous
allons essayer de comprendre de façon
didactique ce qu est l octroi de mer
alors qu'est ce que c'est exactement
alors l'octroi de mer c'est une
imposition spécifique appliquée aux
départements d'outre-mer qui a été
validé par l'union européenne jusqu'au
31 décembre 2020 il s'agit d'une donc de
l'impôt indirect communal qui s'applique
à deux types d'opérations donc les les
importations de marchandises mais
également la production locale dacquois
coincé à l'octroi de mer à l'origine
l'octroi de mer était une taxation qui
s'appliquait uniquement à l'importation
et qui servait à financer les communes
c'est donc une source de financement des
communes c'est vrai que durant
l'évolution l'octroi de mer il ya eu
plusieurs objectifs premiers objectifs
très clairement affiché le financement
des communes et dans les années 70 le
conseil général de la martinique a donc
utilisé le trad mais a comme un outil de
développement
c'est à dire qu'en utilisant une
taxation différenciée entre productions
locales importations a permis
l'émergence de tissu industriel local
plus créateurs d'emplois que
l'importation
c'est pour permettre en fait c'est pour
permettre à la production locale
d'exister exactement à ce qui permet la
production locale d'exister ce n'est pas
l'octroi de mer en soit c'est donc la
modularité des taux ce qu'on appelle le
différentiel de taxation entre
productions locales importations et
c'est un outil de développement
fondamental et c'est à partir de ce
différentiel que dans les années 70
toutes les marques lequel que vous
connaissez tous le tissu industriel
économique de la martinique avec les
entreprises que vous connaissez
actuellement les marques auxquelles sont
attachés des consommateurs ont été créés
c'est grâce à ce site différentiel là
que ça a été que nos marques existent
aujourd'hui c'est la collectivité
territoriale qui fixe les taux
là exactement alors il s'agit d'un impôt
effectivement communal mais dont la
compétence relève effectivement donc de
la région et donc de la ctm c'est donc
là c'est m
qui fixe les taux l'essentiel de l'arsel
d'octroi de mer allant effectivement aux
budgets des communes
il y à différentes eaux selon les
produits exactement alors le principe
édicté par l'union européenne c'est la
même taxation pour une même catégorie de
produits à l'exception effectivement du
différentiel donc en fonction des
produits il ya ce qu'on appelle des
produits de liste on va pas rentrer dans
les détails techniques des produits de
nuit c'est effectivement il donc il ya
des taux différents en fonction des
produits
est-ce qu'il ya aussi des taux
différents entre les territoires par
exemple contre la martinique et la
guadeloupe à skis un taudis taux
différents tout à fait sachant que
chaque conseil régional donc la 7ème et
la région guadeloupe a la compétence de
fixation des taux il peut y avoir des
taux différents il faut savoir que nous
sommes entre la martinique et la
guadeloupe nous sommes dans un marché
unique et les églises exécutifs
régionaux essaye d'harmoniser
effectivement ces taux entre les
promesses qu'ils y arrivent parce que
c'est toujours le cas parce qu'on a
souvent entendu qu'il était plus facile
de thomas dire de faire transférer une
marchandise en guadeloupe et que ça
coûtait moins cher
l on arrive à harmoniser les taux alors
tous des parents moniz et mais on va
dire il ya des lignes directrices
d'harmonisation les exécutifs régionaux
se rencontrent justement pour tenter
cette harmonisation simplement parce que
nous sommes dans un marché unique et
vous avez parfaitement compris la
problématique
il faut donc effectivement harmoniser
les taux pour ne pas avoir des effets
d'aubaine d'importation sur un
territoire plutôt qu'un autre
très bien alors le 31 décembre 2020 le
dispositif arrive à échéance et vous
avez signé une charte pour demander
qu'il soit qui ne sera pas modifié
pourquoi alors nous avons demandé une
charte pour reconduire le dispositif je
vous disais en début d'entretien que le
dispositif est validé par l'union
européenne jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 et
donc nous demandons au gouvernement
français d' entreprendre avec les
instances européennes une négociation
pour le reconduire pourquoi il faut
savoir que l'europe autorise ce
dispositif
tout simplement parce que l'europe
retenait que dans nos territoires pour
développer l'industrie
nous supportons déchu
et donc nous devons démontrer
l'existence de ces surcoûts et en
démontrant l'existence de sûr que sur
coup nous pouvons aujourd'hui bénéficier
de ce dispositif et donc du différentiel
de taxation entre productions locales et
importations aujourd'hui quelque elle
l'inscrit quel disque est si haut risque
ce que l'octroi de mer soient modifiées
que vous ne soyez pas entendu quels sont
les risques
mais le risque écouter les dernières
déclarations de la ministre des dom et
vous aller tout de suite voir le risque
et il ne s'agit pas d'un combat
catégorielles aujourd'hui que dit la
ministre
la ministre au début de ce2 7 de sa
volonté réformatrice est dit l'octroi de
mer les facteurs de vie chère ensuite
elle dit
pourquoi avoir deux systèmes de taxation
up octroi de mer et tva et donc et
ensuite on nous dit oui il faut
préserver la production locale mais on
ne nous explique pas quel dispositif
permettra effectivement de compenser les
surcoûts donc le risque
il existe il est grand il existe et le
risque c'est la disparition donc des
entreprises de transformation pas
seulement industriel industrielles
artisanales mais également agricoles et
donc c'est un débat de société il ne
s'agit pas du tout d'un débat
catégorielles et il est important que
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques qu'il
s'agisse des consommateurs qu'il
s'agisse des politiques parce que sa
finance les communes qu'ils s'agissent
des autres acteurs économiques
s'emparent de ce débat parce que le
risque est réel aujourd'hui mais ce que
ce n'est pas une réalité
quand on dit quand il dit que l'octroi
de mer de contribuer à la vie chère
alors lorsque lorsqu'on veut tuer son
chien on dit qu'il a la rage
c'est typiquement comme ça que le débat
était posée est ce la raison pour
laquelle nous disons que le débat était
tronqué aujourd'hui il faut que vous
sachiez que au niveau national le taux
de tva
le taux normal est de 20% aujourd'hui en
martinique nous bénéficions nos taux
réduit de 8 5%
et lorsque vous regardez la taxation
moyen de l'octroi de mer on est à peu
près aux alentours de 10%
donc qu'on veut quand vous cumulez taux
réduits en martinique 8 5%
octroi de mer à peu près 10% ça fait 18
5 % versus un taux normal en france
hexagonale ces 20%
donc aujourd'hui nous
ils ont que le prétendu effets
inflationnistes la première n'a pas été
démontrée lorsqu'on se réfère au taux de
tva nationales
il est totalement inexistant et aucune
évaluation sérieuse ne vient démontrer
cet effet inflationniste
alors monsieur françois est reçue les
prenons un exemple fabrication de prix
un produit sort en
hors taxes il est importé en martinique
il alors comment est fabriqué le cri
exactement alors le prix c'est complexe
mais en tout cas le coût de revient du
produit je vais vous l'expliquer alors
aujourd'hui l'octroi de mer je vous
disais s'applique aux produits à
l'entrée du territoire c'est à dire que
lorsqu'un produit arrive en martinique
nous prenons la valeur du produit plus
effectivement de transport ce qu'on
appelle la valeur civ du produit auquel
s'applique effectivement le taux
d'octroi de mer dits externes
ça c'est pour les produits importés mais
les producteurs locaux également facture
de l'octroi de mer et ça s'appelle le
trône mère interne donc sur la base du
prix de cession du produit lors de la
première mise à la consommation
nous appliquons nous producteurs locaux
également un taux de 1re d'accord donc
deux taux d'octroi de mercy un produit
importé auquel on ajoute donc les marges
distributeurs et cetera et cetera
mais auquel on ajoute la tva tout à fait
aujourd'hui la tva s'applique sur le
coût de revient du produit alors il se
trouve que dans la pratique la tva
s'applique effectivement lorsque vous
prenez l'exemple de produits importés je
vous expliquais que leur revient
c'est effectivement la valeur cible du
produit donc valeur du produit plus
transport plus hot rod mer il se trouve
que la distribution de sage en général
applique un taux de tva sur le coût de
revient du produit
sauf que quand vous relisez bien les
textes la législation vous dit la base
de tact actions de l'octroi de mer ses
ors et de la tva par non c'est hors
outre-mer est donc aujourd'hui il suffit
simplement d'appliquer les textes pour
exclure de la base effectivement de
taxation
l'octroi de mer de doigté vers l'octroi
de mer donc on peut
diminuer les prix à ce moment là est-ce
qu'il faut il faut donc revoir la base
de calcul il s'agit pas de revoir la
base de calcul il s'agit d'appliquer
simplement la législature actuelle et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
d'autres déclarations nous faisons la
distinction très clairement entre le
volet de l'octroi de mer qui concerne la
production locale et le volet de notre
eau de mer qui concerne l'importation et
nous disons sur la base des produits
importés non concurrents de la
production de cale nous pouvons tout
envisagé y compris une baisse de la
taxation prenons l'exemple des pièces
détachées automobiles il n'y a pas de
producteur en martinique de pièces
détachées automobiles on pourrait très
bien décider de baisser le niveau de
taxation sur les pièces détachées
automobiles ça ne nous pose pas de
problème sauf que l'on dit attention ces
ressources là qui sont des ressources
qui finance les communes ne viennent pas
abonder les recettes des communes et
donc il faut compenser donc il faut que
l'état compense c'est donc la solidarité
nationale qui doit compenser
effectivement la baisse de la taxation
je vous donne un exemple qu'elle va
reprendre effectivement ce que
représente pour que les auditeurs
comprennent ce que représente
véritablement l'opra nerfs dans les
communes je vous cite deux communes
rivière-pilote et et rivière salée
aujourd'hui le la recette de gestion
courante de ria pilote c'est à peu près
11 millions d'euros
l'octroi de mer ses 6 millions
c'est-à-dire 56 % du budget de cette
commune prenant rivière salée rivière
salée la recette de gestion courante
2018 c'est aux alentours de 14 millions
d'euros recettes d'octroi de mer 6 5
millions d'euros 46 % du budget des
communes
donc vous voyez bien que aujourd'hui une
baisse de la taxation implique une
compensation intégrale pour les communes
pour ne pas déséquilibrer l'horrible
financier alors vu que les dotations
gêné que la dotation générale de
fonctionnement diminuent déjà là est ce
que la baisse ce n'est pas hypothétique
baisse demandée au gouvernement qui
baissent déjà la dotation générale est
ce que c'est pas hypothétique
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
disons que ce débat est engagé de façon
très légère parce qu'effectivement
lorsqu'on envisage de modifier un
dispositif
il faut voir toutes les conséquences de
cette modification y compris ce que vous
disiez effectivement l'état baissent la
dotation globale de fonctionnement et on
nous explique aujourd'hui qu'il
semblerait qu'il qu'il veuille le
compenser mais le vrai débat n'est pas
là il s'agit de
tables débat de société la question
c'est quelle économie voulons-nous est
ce que nous voulons d'une économie avec
une production locale ou simplement nous
voulons que nos territoires soient des
territoires de consommation et
d'importation c'est un vrai débat c'est
la raison pour laquelle ce débat ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas un débat
technique
ce n'est pas un débat catégorielles
c'est pour ça que tout le monde doit
s'emparer de ce débat est aujourd'hui ce
que dit le gouvernement en tout cas les
pistes que semble avancer le
gouvernement c'est simplement de
remplacer octroi de mer par la tva
nationales et donc il faut savoir que
nous n'aurons pas à priori d'après les
d'après en tout cas les pistes du
gouvernement pas de pas de l'octroi de
mer mais une tva une tva à l'identique
du national à 20%
ça ne change strictement rien sur les
prix ça met en risque les finances des
collectivités locales avec possiblement
une augmentation de la fiscalité locale
ayant été en définitive une baisse des
prix peut ne pas se traduire par une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et ce sont toutes les autres
tous mais outre mer qui sont vent debout
face à cette situation
cette proposition tout à fait aux gens
ville l'ensemble des socioprofessionnels
des quatre dom vous vont adopter la même
motion sur leur territoire il faut que
vous sachiez que que monsieur macro et
eto'o apte à la réunion début début
décembre
il semblerait qu'ils aient des annonces
qui vont être faites et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut s'emparer de ce
débat de société pour savoir quel type
d'économie nous voulons dans nos
territoires
je vous remercie françois-ier seleçao
qui a déterminé bonne journée l écoute
de nos programmes